à ces deux occasions c'est la plus belle
phrase et le soir de son interview on ne
laisse pas tomber un homme à terre
et puis j'étais dans la bataille je
pensais juste à sauter barrière après
barrières et je n'avais pas de raison de
ne pas le croire
je pense que j'ai compté pour lui mais
j'étais au bout nous n'avons jamais eu
d'explication de fond et c'est vrai que
ça quand elle dit on la suède qu'on ne
laisse pas tomber un homme qui est à
terre elle a soutenu jusqu'au bout et
après on a l'impression qu'elle l'a
soutenu et une fois qu elle s'est dit
bon ça y est c'est passé elle la mission
mais on est quand même étrange ses
phrases par ce que ça veut donc dire un
homme à terre qu'elle a toujours vécue
en fait dominique strauss kahn comme une
victime
alors qu'a priori il n'était pas bien
sûr le débat c'est est ce qu'il est
victime et coupable
et visiblement elle a toujours vu comme
un homme est à terre donc comme une
victime l'a jamais elle n'a jamais douté
de sa parole alors que le monde entier
quand même avec d'énormes doutes et on
continue même en avoir aujourd'hui
alors la question qu'on doit poser aussi
aurait été voulait être première dame de
france saint clair contrairement à tout
ce qu'on a dit je n'avais pas envie
d'aller à l'elysée
lui non plus n'avait pas très envie
d'ailleurs c'était un enchaînement de
circonstances puisque je vous rappelle
c'est vrai que avant cette affaire un
remix strauss kahn et oui les corps oui
parce que les élections ont dit tout ce
que c'est vrai que dans ciels de la
fantaisie même disait que c'était son
principal adversaire et qu'il avait
envoyé la balle ouin ouin famille pour
donner le droit ni de rien
est tranquille sans lui et c'est vrai
que quand ça et quand c'est tombé on
sait on a tous aussi on s'est tous dit
c'est un complot mapou et écarté
dominique strauss kahn de la course à la
présidentielle
favori exactement était d'environ 12
elle dit qu lui non plus n'avait pas
envie d'être président je suis pas
vraiment un scoop puisqu'il n'a jamais
vraiment eu envie d'être président il ya
même une anecdote lors de la précédente
présidentielle quand il est candidat aux
primaires à moment donné il a plus envie
d'y aller mais il est dans une réunion
avec ses ennemis politiques et il dit
voilà ce qui j'ai pas envie d'y aller je
pense que ça va pas bien se passer et c
est comme à dellys 10 mai dominique la
décision n'appartient pas
c'est tes amis qui vont voter ils ont
fait un vote et dominique strauss kahn
s'est retrouvé contraint d'être candidat
aux primaires il s'est fait balayer à
l'époque par ségolène royal
il n'y a jamais eu très envie se connaît
depuis quand même il sait ce qu'ils
aiment et ce qu'ils aiment pas dans la
vie et ce avec eux présents à un public
pour lui c'était quelque chose de
compliqué donc au fond il n'a jamais eu
vraiment très envie de le scoop c'est
qu'elle dit que l mais elle n'avait pas
en vrai et alors qu'on disait beaucoup
que lé première dame de france est
certain